bello a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovissimo video sono fi j e oggi
siamo in un video un po particolare un
po particolare perché l'avete visto
magari dal dal titolo o dalla durata
alle video insomma con cui oggi farlo
video un po diverso dal solito perché
sarà un video senza tagli umido uncut
giampiero non può contare in questi
giorni perché si sta trasferendo e
quindi quale migliore occasione per
trattare uno degli argomenti che di più
affligge il mio canale da da sempre da
quando l'ho aperto che è una domanda e
l'altra una domanda la domanda è toni j
mi saluti mi saluti in un video mi
saluti in generale ecco questa è la
domanda che io ricevo di più da sempre
rilanciamo un sacco di volte al giorno e
attualmente io ancora ignoro l'utilità
di un mio saluto non ho mai capito cosa
in your l'utilità di un mio saluto ma
nonostante questo continua riceverne in
massa di domande regione quindi ho
trovato certo cercherà di trovare una
soluzione per farsi queste domande
spariscano
come faccio semplicemente ho pensato di
salutare
tutti ok c'è quindi io in questo video
saluterò tutti tutti vuol dire che
diciamo alla fine di questo video
nessuno potrà più dirmi famiglia in
saluti perché in questo video
racchiudera tutti i saluti di cui le
persone hanno evidentemente un sacco
bisogno quindi io ho aperto un sito in
questo modo davanti che contiene
all'incirca mille e 700 nomi italiani
scritto qua
tra ci sono un sacco di nomi molto rari
anche oltre che quelli più comuni no
quindi io in questo video e leggero
tutti quanti
dovrebbe teoricamente poi risolversi il
problema del bayonne i saluti quindi io
passerò il tempo quindi qualcosa o
qualcuno ora volumi a saluto se mai
doveste incontrare qualcuno
che magari tra una parola e l'altra ci
metto in mezzo il fai cenni saluti ecco
linkate di questo video che dovrebbe
essere poi risolto il problema allora
una piccola premessa ci sono 1700 nomi
partirò in ordine alfabetico
sono suddivisi i nomi maschili e nomi
femminili quindi prima a tutti i nomi
con la a maschili poi tutti i nomi con
la a femminili e poi si passa alla
lettera b maschili femminili vetro cima
si va bene quindi se siete in questo
video perché sentita necessità io mio
saluto andate proprio nel punto
in ordine alfabetico dove iniziò il
vostro nome la lettera del vostro nome è
cercato appunto questo nome perché al
99,9 per cento dei casi c'è ok perché
sono è una raccolta incredibile quindi
c'è quasi sicuramente
bene direi che possiamo cominciare
abbiamo un sorso d'acqua perché sarà una
cosa un po lunga quindi
devo essere allen è un allenamento
questo è uno sport però e voce il tono
di voce un po più basso del solito
perché da quando ho fatto la 24ore
ragazzi ho perso un po la voce quindi vi
chiedo scusa se fanno un po più
a smr però è solo per una questione di
dove riposare un po perché poi cosa un
po la voce perché invitato mi va via
quindi parlo un po così
direi che possiamo cominciare ragazzi
allora partiamo con i nomi maschili con
la lettera a
ok
ciao abaco ciao hubble d'anzio ciao
abbondio ciao abdon e ciao abelardo ciao
babele ciao a menzio ciao abb
ciao abraham yo
ciao abramo ciao a calcio ciao a cario
ciao accursio ciao achille ciao al
ciglio ciao agiscono ciao acrisio ciò ad
e lardo ciao ad alberto ciao ad alfredo
scava d'alberto dal prezzo due nomine
ciao ad alberto ciao adalgiso ciao dal
rico ciao adamo
ciao aldo ciao dell'art ciao ed alberto
ciao adelchi ciao adelfo
ciola del cardo ciao adelmo ciao ad e.on
adeodato ciao adolfo ciao a donne ciao
adriano ciao ad rione ciao afro ciao
agabio ciao agamennone ciao ha capito
ciao ragazzi
ciao e gen ore ciao hudgens agesilao
ciao agostino ciao agrippa ciao aiace
ciao aiutano ciao aimone ciò aladino
ciao alla mano ciao qualano
ciao alarico ciao albano
ciao alberico ciao alberto
ciao alpino tranquillo ciao alboino ciò
al brico ciao alceo ciò alceste ciao
archiviate ciao alcide facile ciao al
chino ciao aldo ciao aldobrando ciao
alejandro ciao aleardo ciao aleramo
ciao alessandro ciao alessio
ciao alfio ciao alfonzo ciao alfredo
ciao avviso ciao alighiero
ciao almerigo ciao al miro ciao
bella
ciao bella ciao
salvaro ciao alviero ciao alvise ciao
amabile ciao amadeo ciao amando ciao
amanzio ciao amaranto ciao amato ciao
amatore ciao amauri ciao ambrogio ciao
ambrosiano
ciao amideo ciao amelio ciao amerigo
ciao amico
ciao amilcare ciao amintore ciao amleto
ciao amore ciao amore ciao amore ciao
ampelio ciao anna feto ciao andrea ciao
angelo ciao aniceto ciao aniello
ciao annibale ciao ansaldo ciao conselmo
ciao anzovino
ciao antelmo ciao antero ciao antimo
ciao antino ciao antioco ciao antonello
ciao antonio ciao apollinare ciao apollo
ciotole io c'ho aquino ciao araldo ciao
maratone ciò arcadio cerca varchi mente
ciò accalchi calci valdo ciò ha detto
ciò arduino ciò ha reso
ciao algimiro ciao marco ciao a riardo
ciò ariberto shahriari o socialists o
aristarco ciò aristeo cio aristide ciò
ariston e ciò il sociali stefano i
giovani sto telegramma ciao armando ciò
arminio ciao arnaldo ciao aronne ciao
arrivo ciò arturo ciao ascanio ciao
asdrubale ciao asimo there ciao assunto
ciao asterio ciao astianatte ciao a tale
oh ciao atanasio ciao athos ciao attila
ciao attigliano
ciao attivo ciao roberto ciaccio augusto
ciao aureliano ciao aurelio ciao auguro
ciao ausilio ciao averardo ciao azelio e
ciao azelio e questi erano i nomi con la
a maschili l'unico la femminili ciao
abbondanza ciao acilia ciao a da ciao ad
alberta ciao adalgisa ciao addolorata
ciao adelaide ciao adelasia ciao adele
ciao adelina ciao latina
ciao adria ciao adriana ciao agape ciao
agata ciao agnese ciao a pristina ciao
ciao alba ciao alberto ciò valdina ciao
alcina ciao aida
e ciao alessandra ciao alessia ciao
alfonzo ciao alfredo ciao alice ciao
alida ciao alina ciao allegra ciao alma
ciao valter ciao amalia ciao lamanda
ciao amata ciao ambra ciò va meglio
a mina ciao anastasia
ciao anatolia ciao ancilla ciao
andromeda ciao angelo ciao angelica cha
vanità ciao anna ciao anna bella
ciao anna grazia ciao anna maria ciao
annunziata ciao antea
ciao antigone ciao antonella ciao
antonio ciao a bollino ciao apollonia
ciò abbia ciao arabella ciao argelia
ciao arianna ciao armida ciao artemisa
ciao bella ciao asia
ciao assunta ciao astrid ciao antanasia
ciao aurelia ciao aurora ciao ausilia
ciao ausiliatrice ciao ciao ciao azelia
e ciao azzurra aveva finito i nomi con
la a
andiamo con i nomi con la vita beh
questa tecnica cioè questa atletica
atletica momento leggera atletica
bricola b
ciao pacco ciao mai abbassare child è
ricco ciao marco ciao baldomero ciao
baldovino ciao barbarigo ciao marco ciao
bardot miano ciao barnaba ciobar sava
ciao parsi meno ciao bartolo ciao
bartolomeo
ciao basileo o basilio ciao passiano
ciao bastiano ciao battista ciao beato
ciao bellino ciò beltramo ciao benedetto
ciao beniamino ciao benigno ciao benito
ciao e benvenuto ciao berardo ciao
berengario ciao bernardo
ciao veronico chopper tolto il rifugio
ciao bertoldo ciao biagio ciao vi piano
ciò window domino scioperino ciò buona
giunta ciao bonaldo ciao bonaventura una
vita con i faccio ciò bonito ciao boris
ciao morto lo show brancaleone ciao
brando
ciao bruno ciao bruto
don minico
ciao babila ciao bambina ciao barbara
ciao bartolomeo ciao basilia ciao
bassilla ciao matilda ciao beata ciao
beatrice ciao belinda ciao benedetta
ciao beniamina ciao benigna
ciao benvenuta ciò per iniziare ciao
bernadetta ciao bella ciao bianca ciò di
piana ciao beach ciao brigida ciao
brigitta ciao bruna ciao bruni le
novit colaci
ciao carino ciao caio ciocca l'amico
ciao calcedonio c'è un callisto ciao
calogero ciao camillo ciò candido ciò
canti dio ciò che anziano ciao carlo
ciao carmelo ciao termine ciao caronte
ceo carbonio ciò casimiro ciò che siano
già cassio shock associò cataldo gioca
tutto ciò cecco ceci ciò cecilio celso
ciao cesare
ciao ciao cesareo ciao cherubino ciotti
a freddo e ciò via caldone scherza ciao
chino ciao cipriano soci lancio ciriaco
shop
cirillo ciancimino cianci riccia un ciro
chocola renzio ciao claudio ciao creando
c'è un e mente ciao cronico ciao crimaco
shock linio ciao clodomiro ciò però
dover ciarlo col manu chao col marzio
ciao colomban ciò colombo ciò concetto
c'è concordia con il bilancio coreno ciò
coriolano ciao cornelio cio ha coronato
ciao corrado ciò cosimo cosma ciò
costante ciò costantino ciao costanzo
show crei menzio ciao crescente ciò
crescenzio soccer crespignano ciao
crispino ciò cristaldo ciò cristiano
ciò cristo crocefisso ciao
cuniberti occupi do
femminili ciao calogera ciao calpurnia
ciao camelia ciò camilla ciao cani da
ciò capitolina ciao carina ciao carla
ciao carlotta giocarmela ciao cullman
ciao carla ciao carolina ciao casilda
ciao casimira ciao cassandra ciao
cassiopea ciao catena ciao caterina ciò
che ci piace o celeste ciao celina ce li
nea ciao chiara ciao cinzia ciao cirilla
ciao clara ciao claudia ciao clelia ciao
clemenza ciao cleo cio cleofe ciò che ho
quattro ciaoblog clorinda quinta ciao
colomba ciao concetta ciao consolata
ciao cora ciò cornelia ciao corinne
ciao cornelia ciao cosima già abbastanza
ciò crescenzia ciò cristiana ciao
cristina ciao crocefisso ciò cronista
ciò crew cunegonda
ciao cuffia
lettera d
ciao da ciano ciao da ciò ciao dagoberto
ciò dalmazio ciao damaso ciao damiano
ciao damocle ciao daniele ciao danilo
ciao da neo badante ciao dario ciao
davide
ciao da pino solo decimo ciò delfino
ciao demetrio ciò detto ciò le mostre
nel solo tratto desiderato c'è un
desiderio ciò di mosciaro diego giardino
ciao diocleziano ciò diodoro ciò diogene
ciò il mio meglio c'è unione ciao
dionigi ciò dionisio ciao tipo ciao
dotato ciao domenico
ciao domizio ciao domiziano ciao
donatello ciao donato ciao doriano ciao
doroteo ciao duccio ciao dulio ciao
durante
temi
ciao dafne ciao dalida ciao dalila ciao
damiana ciao daniela ciao d'aria
ciao de anna ciao deborah ciao degna
ciao delfino
ciao devia ciò dell'inda ciò delizia ciò
che mentre ciò che ha tante teste destra
ciao desdemona desiderata ciao devota
ciao diamante ciao diana ciò dianora
ciao diletta scianina sodio data ciao
dionisia ciao dott.sa ciao dolores ciao
domenica ciao donata ciao donatella ciao
donna ciao dora ciò dorotea suina e ciao
dolina
ciao e berardo cioe clesio ciao edgardo
giovedì il berto ciao l'idillio ciao il
mondo ciao edoardo ciao efisio ciao
efrem ciao egeo ciao egidio ciao ag
nardò ciao egisto ciò eleuterio ciao
belli
d'elia cioè dio
ciao eliano ciao e livio ciao eligio
celio ciao eliodoro ciao eliseo ciao
elita cioè il nocciolo elogio cioè il
video cioè il vecchio cioè il vino cioè
ciao
ciao emanuele ciao emidio ciao emiliano
ciao emilio ciao emerico ciò empireo
ciao endrigo ciao enea cioe ne con e
cioè mio ciao enrico ciao enzo ciao
eraclide ciao eraldo ciao erardo ciao
erasmo ciao alberto ciao ercolano ciao
ercole ciao elenia ciao eriberto ciao e
ricco ciao armanno ciao ermenegildo ciao
hermes ciao m.te ciao armi lo ciao
erminio ciao ernesto ciao eros ciao esaù
ciao è lo specchio
ciao batterie
ciao ettore ciao euclide ciao eusebio
ciale un fermo ciao è un fronio eugenio
ciao esempio ciao ciao eustorgio allo
studio cioè ciao e italia aveva altro
cioè quando ci aveva visto cha all
evasione berardo ciao il video ciao e
podio cioe pre mondo ciao e se chiede
ciao ezio
femminile ciao ebbe cioè da cioè del
belga cioe ditta edvige
ciao egizia ciao ciao e light ciao bella
ciao elena ciao eleonora ciao elettra
ciao eliana ciao elide cioè limena ciao
elisa ciao elisabetta ciao elisa ciao
bella ciao e lolita ciao elsa ciao e il
via ciao elvira ciao emanuela ciao
emilia ciao emiliana ciao ciao in linea
ciao enrica ciao era cla ciao herrman
ermelinda charming ermenegarda ciao
ermenegilda ciao arminia ciao ernesta
ersilia ciao esmeralda cioe stella ciao
ester ciao esterina ciao eufemia ciao è
un frate ciao eugenia ciao eulalia ciao
eroina dice ciao eusebia ciao eutalia
ciao eva ciao evangelina ciao evelina
nicola f
ciao fabiano ciao fabio ciao fabrizio
ciao famiano ciao falso ciao fazio ciò
fedele ciao federico ciao fedro ciao
felice
ciao feliciano ciao ferdinando
ciao fermiano ciao fermo ciao fernando
ciao ferruccio c'è un fesso
fine finanziano ciò fidenzio ciò
filiberto c'è filippo ciò filomeno ciao
florenzia know ciao fiorenzo ciao
flaviano ciao flavio ciao flaiano
ciao floriano ciao folco ciao fortunato
ceo fosco ciao francesco ciao franco
ciao frigo ciao frontignano ciao full
berto ciao fulgenzio ciao fulvio ciao
furio ciao full seo ciauscolo
noi minico
f.cio fabiana ciò fabi fa viola già
fatti ma ciao falsa ciao federica ciao
fedora ciao felice ciao felicità
ciao fernanda ciò che ammetta ciao
filippa filomena ciao fiordaliso c'è un
fiore ciao fiorella ciao fiorenza ciao
flaminia ciao flavia australiana ciao
francia floriana jolie ghiacciatori
nacho foca ciò fortunata ciò fosca ciao
francasca o francesca ciao fulvia
con la g ciao gabino ciao gabriele ciao
gaetano ciao dagli occhi ciao gaio ciao
galdino ciao galeazzo ciò che li neo ceo
gallicano ciò gandolfo ciao garimberti
ciao gaspare ciao gastone ciò che holden
ziò gaudino ciao gaudiero ciao fino a
oggi e do gedeone ciao geminiano ciao
generoso ciao genesio ciao gennaro ciao
gentile ciao genziano ciao gerardo ciao
gela simo ciao geremia ciao gerino
ciao germano ciao gerolamo ciao geronimo
ciao geronzio ciao gervasio ciao a
gesualdo
ciao gherardo john zhao giacinto ciao
giacobbe ciao giacomo ciao già oggi è
vero ciao gianbattista ciao gian
battista clan ciao giancarlo ciao
giandomenico ciao gianfranco
gianluca ciò gianluigi cio gianmarco ciò
che a maria ciao giammario ciao gianni
ciao giampaolo ciao giampiero ciao
gianpietro ciao gianuario ciao giasone
ciò gilberto ciò gildo ciao gillo ciao
ginetto ciao gino ciao giochino ciao
giobbe
ciao gioberto ciò giocondo e ciò joele
ceo john a
ciao gionata ciao giordano
ciao giorgio ciao giosuè ciao giosuè le
ciao giotto ciao giovanni ciao giove
ciao giovent hino ceo menzio ciao
girardot ciao girolamo ciao giuda
ciao giulia giuliano ciao giulio ciao
giuseppe ciao giustiniano ciao giusto
ciao claudio goffredo ciao ciao
commercio con dolfo giogo nerico ciao
gonzaga ciao board non so gioco tanto
gioca cigliano ciò grecia sono grato
ciao graziano ciao gregorio ciao
grimaldo ciò fu alberto ciao gualtiero
ciao guelfo ciao guerrino cia puglia
roberto ciao guido ciao guiscardo
choules e mingo un mesi ndaw ciao
gustavo
piumini quasi ciao gabriella
giogaia ciò che la tea ciao gaudenzio
ciao detto mina ciao gertrude gemma
generosa agenesia genoveffa ciao germanà
ciao gertrude ciao vita giacinta
ciao giada ciao gigliola ciao gilda cio
oggi l'oggi viola già oggi niente ciao
giochino ciao ciao gioconda ciao gioia
ciao giorgia ciao giovanna ciao gisella
ciò giuditta ciao giulia ciao giuliana
giulitta ciao giuseppe ciao giuseppina
ciao giusta
ciao lenta ciao
mi sono perso gloria
ciao gode berta ciao godiva ciao grazie
ciao graziana ciao graziella ciao greta
ciao griselda ciao guenda ciò guendalina
e ciò guenda linda
9 collati
ciao jacopo ciò jacopone anche iacopino
ciaia goccia icaro omicidio ciò video
ingenio ciao ingino ciao ignazio cia
vigor ciao ilario ciao ildebrando ciao
ildefonso ciao in libia ciao illuminato
ciò immacolato ciò incrocia innocente
ciao innocenzo ciao iorio ciao ippocrate
ciò in polito ciao ireneo ciao isacco
ciao isaia zhao yi sky ore ciao isidoro
ciao ismaele ciao italo ciao ivan ciao
ivano ciao ivanhoe ciao vivo ciao ivone
troiani rashaida ciao idea zhao yi jing
zhao ilaria il dacia ildegarda ciò il
the con da ciao ileana ciao ilenia ciao
il a ciò il bacio alimenta ciao
immacolata ciao incoronata ciao ines
ciao innocenza ciò iolanda ciao iole
ciao jona ciao io ne so io né ciao irene
ciao ciao ciao irma cimina ciao elisa
ciao isabella visite ciao signora ciò
risulta ciao italia e civetta
amico la l
già ladislau ciao lamberto ciò
lancillotto show landolfo ciò non franco
rappocciolo dentinho ciò vogliamo cioè
dopo toni nocciola 00 ciò leandro ciao
leo cia leonardo ciò leoni ciao leonida
ciao leonio cioè non solo quando ciò
leopoldo cholet e riuso ha liberato ciao
liberatore ciao liberio ciao libero ciao
liberto ciò liborio ciao lidio cio lieto
ciolino cioè lisandro ciavolino ciao
livio ciao lodovico ciao loreno ciao
lorenzo ciao loris ciao luca ciao
luciano ciao ciao luciano ciao ludovico
ciao luigi
formicola l ciao lara ciao laura ciao
lavinia ciao leo cholet a
faleria ciao le nocciole olio ciò
leonilda ciò leontina ciò letizia ciao
lì a giuliana ciao liberata suo liborio
ciao licia jolie dania ciao libia ciao
liliana chao pin da
ciao lisa ciao libia chao li diano ciao
lodovica cia loredana cia lorella ciao
lorena ciao lorenzo ciao loretta ciao
loriano ciao luana ciao luce ciao lucia
ciao luciana ciao lucilla ciao lucrezia
ciao ludovica ciao luigi ciao luisa ciao
luminosa ciao luna
l'amico m
ciao macario ciò ma camera ciò non
facciamo maggiorino ciò ma io dico ciao
marco ciao mamante ciancio c'è un ma
netto ciao alfredo ciao nido ciani lo
show mansueto ciao manuele ciao marcello
ciò marciano ciao marco ciao mariano
ciao marino ciao mario
ciao marolo ciao martino ciao marzio
ciao massimiliano ciao massimo c'è un ma
torniano ciao matteo ciao mattia ciao
maurilio ciao maurizio e ciao mauro
ciao medardo ciao medoro ciao melania
ciao meritiate ciao melchiorre ciao
melenzio
melezio ciao menardo ciao menelao ciao
meneo ciao me non è ciao mercurio un
metallo
ciao metrò fan e ciao michelangelo ciao
michele ciao milo ciao minervino ciao
mirko ciao mirko anche con la k ciao
mirò cleto ciao misael e ciao modesto
ciao con aldo ciao monitore ciao moreno
so cos'è ci siamo
mi dico
ciò magari a ciò maddalena ciò mafalda
domanda maila ciao manuela ciao mara
ciao marana ciao marcella c'è maretta
ciao margherita ciao mareta ciao maria
ciao
marianna ciao marika ciao marinella ciao
marilena ciao marina ciao marine
marinetta
cio marina ciao marisa ciao maria ciao
marta ciao martyna ciao valuta ciao
marzia ciao massima ciao matilde ciao
mauro ciao melania ciao melissa ciao
belli melitina ciao meno dora ciao per
cedere ciò che salina ciao mia
ciao michela ciao milena ciao mamma ciao
minaccia minerva ciao minervino ciao
miranda ciao mirella ciao miriam ciao
mirta ciao maria ciao monica ciao morena
e ciao morgana
noi con la n ciao una mazzeo ciao
napoleone ciao narciso ciao nacional set
ciao natale
ciao nazario c'è un hazare non c'è
un'altra ragione o neo polo c'è un
europeo jean nereo c'è un è diciamo
nestore jonica retta diceva c'è un
incrocio di certo c'è un eccesso di
coach nicodemo ciao nicola ciao nicolò
ciao lignano ciao nino gioè c'è un
alberto c'è uno strano ciao nunzio ciao
don e
non stava periodo questo già un inizio
nomi femminili clan ciò nadia ciao
natalia ciao natalino
ciao ne va ciao nei lea c'è un mix
lanciamo nicoletta ciao milde ciao nina
john in francia universal one mi ciao
marina ciao norma c'è una bella ciao
annuccia ciao
annunziata già iniziata ciao detta cia
odilia ciao feria ciao olga ciao olimpia
sono direttamente quello senza
annunciarlo non mi
collaudo per chiamare maschi pero
prima pagina unità qua può essere ancora
comunque nicolò maschili ciao donne ciao
poderico gioco di idonei ciao po duri
coach a olimpio ciao polito ciao poi gli
piero ciao omar ciao omero ciao onesto
ciao onofrio ciao bonorino cia onorio
ciao orazio ciao polizio ciao foreste
ciao prof ciao podio ciao orlando ciao
oronzo ciao polsino ciao ciao ortensio
ciao oscar ciao boss mondo ciao a
osvaldo
ciao otello cia ottaviano ciao ottavio
ciao ottone ciao video nicolò fini stop
di co2
ciao ho detto ciao di ghiacciai ofelia
da olga punto cia olimpia ciao linda
ciao libia oliviero ciao ombretta ciao
ondina ciao onesta ciao onorata onorina
cia orchidea cia oriana ciao orietta
ciao protoni nacha ortensia ciao osanna
ciao bottiglia ciao bottiglia
nomi con l'api maschili
ciao facciano cio pacifico ciao pacomio
cio palatino ciò palladio ciop al
marchio cio bancario so con grazia ciao
panfilo ciò pantaleo
pantaleone ciao paolo
ciao pardo ciao paride ciop almeno ciao
pasquale ciò paterniano ciao patrizio
ciò patroclo ciao paolo sfide ciò che le
voci pellin pellegrino ciao beutler ciao
perseo ciò petronio ciao peer angelo
ciao piergiorgio ciò pierluigi ciao pier
marco ciao piero ciao piersilvio
ciao pietro
ciao pio ciao pippo ciao placido ciao
platone ciao plinio ciò plutarco ciò
polidoro ciò polifemo ciao pollione
ciò pompeo
ciao pomponio ciò ponziano ciao ponzio
ciò con sirio ciò porziano ciò postumi
ciò però sede ci offriamo ciao primo
ciao prisco ciò privato ciò procopio ciò
prospero ciao protasio ciao prote'o ciò
prudenzio ciao pubblico ciao popolo e
ciao busi show
da piccoli ciao palladio e ciò palacio
ciao palmira pamela ciao paola ciao
patrizia ciao bellagio per ios ciao
penelope ciao perla ciò petronilla ciao
pia ciao piero
ciao placida ciò polissena ciò porzia
ciao prisca ciò priscilla ciò proserpina
ciò però sperare ciao prudenzia
no chi con la q
maschile
ciao quarto ciao quasimodo gioco erano
quinti illiano ciò puntiglio ciò
quintino ciao quinziano ciao ciao
quirino
nomi con aq femminili ciao quartilla
ciao quieta e ciò cui iter ya
l'unico la r
aspi
ciao rodolfo ciao raffaele ciao ride e
ciao raimondo ciao rainaldo choeur amico
ciao raniero
c'è ora nolfo ciao reginaldo ciao regolo
ciao remigio ciao remo ciao raimondo
ciao renato lorenzo ciao respicio
chavari canio ciao riccardo ciao
richelmo ciao rinaldo ciao rino ciao
robaldo ciao roberto ciao rocco
ciao erodiano ciao rodolfo ciao prodigio
ciao rolando
ciao rolfo ciao romano ciao romeo ciao
romero
ciao romualdo ciao romulo ciao romualdo
ciao rosario ciao rubiano chavez hino
ceo rufo ciao ruggiero ciao roberto e
ciao plutino
noi femminili kohler ciao rachele ciao
raffaella ciao rai nelda ciao rebecca
ciao retina ciao renata ciao riccarda
ciao riina ciao rita ciao roberta ciao
romana ciao romilda ciao romina ciao rom
lanciamo rosa ciò rosaria rosalinda
ciao rosamunda ciao rosanna ciao rosita
ciao rosmunda ciò il sun ciao bella ciao
rufina
riflesse
ciò sabato c'è un sabato sapere ciò
sabino ciò safilo ciao ciao ciao
saladino chauffeur marcia polmone show
sallustio ciao salvatore ciao salvo
samuele ciao sandro ciò sansone ciò
sante ciao santo
ciao sapiente ciao sarà bello ciao
saturniana
ciao saturnino ciao saul ciao saverio
ciao savino ciao sebastiano ciao
secondiano ciao secondo ciao semplice
ciao sempronio ciao sei mesi o ciao seno
forte
ciao serafino ciao serapione
ciao sergio
ciao servizio ciao serviliano c'è un
sesto ciao settimio ciao settimo cielo
severiano c'è un severino ciò severo
chelsea co ciao sicuro ciao sidonio ciò
sigfrido sigismondo sa ciao silvano ciò
silverio ciao silverio ciò silvestro
ciao silvio c'è un simeone ciao simone
ciao silenzio ciò sincronia ciofi
renault ciò siriano ciò si ri cho cho
sirio c'è un filo ciò esiste ciò
soccorso 118 lo pone ciao sostiene
ciò sostenevo ciao sostrato ciao so
spanò
ciao spartaco ciao speranze o ciò
stanislaus all stefano ciao stimiano già
ostili a coach a surano ciao semi turno
novità mini virgola s
ciao sa ma ciò sabina
ciao sabrina ciao samantha ciao simona
ciao sandra ciò santina cio sara ciao
sabina ciò scolastica
ciò sebastiana ciao seconda ciò
secondina ciao 6 four
kaos elena ciao selvaggia ciao
semiramide serafino ciao serena ciò
severa ciò si mila simil ciao sidonia
ciao silvana ciao silvia ciao simona
ciao simonetta ciao siria ciao smeralda
ciao solare ciao sofia ciao sofronia ciò
solo amici ciao sonia ciao speranza ciao
stefania ciao stella ciao susan ciao
salewa
migliorativo
ciao thunder ciao taider ciao tammaro
ciò funk reggae ciao tarcisio ciao dalle
società taziano ciao tazio cia hotel
king show telemaco ciò temistocle cento
val d'orcia teodoro certo è perduto ciao
teo gene ciao terenzio ciao
per terzo ciao tesauro ciao stessi fonte
ciao tibaldo ciao tiberio ciotti bull
sociali con i celti motel chatillon e
ciò detto ciao tiziano cielo tizio certo
via autonoma o tommaso ciao torquato
ciao tosco ceo tranquillo tra langue ciò
tristano ciao pugliano ciao giulio ciao
to reach out turibio e ceo tuzio
l'amico la t
shirt a vita alta marea ciò tarchi
tarquinia ciao tarsilla ciao tanziana
ciò traccia dei clash of the rings
d'elite elica ciao teo datacenter olinda
ciao teodora ciao teresa ciao tenutosi a
ciao tina chow tiziana ciao tosca ciao
tra sea ciao giulia
un amico la
ciao ubaldo ciao bertino ciao berto ciao
google
ciao ugolino ciao un boccione ciao
alberto cialde ricco polisse ciao il
piano ciaculli il ricco
ciao stano ciao ultimo ciao beh umberto
ciao marco ciao utile
già ora neo urbano ciao coordino auguri
lca orificio borsino ciò gurs murs maro
nicola ciao ugolina ciao culpa ciao
puliva ciao un
nomi con la b maschili
ciao valente ciò valentino ciao
valeriano ciao valeri co ciao valerio
ciao valfredo ciò valfrido ciao valter
ciao valter ciao mario vasco chovet
associò vecchio ciò venanzio ciò
venceslao ciò venerando ciao venerio ciò
ventura ciò venustiano ciò che è giusto
ciò verranno ciò verecondo sofferenze
ciò vero ciò che spaziano chavez e ciò
vitigni a bibbiano ciò vi dona ciò che
il freddo ciò che il berto ciao vincenzo
ciò pinton yo ciò viene vado ciò vi in
frigo ciao vinicio ciao virgilio ciao
virginio ciò vione ciò viscardo ciò
vitale cioè vitali coach ha udito ciò
vittore ciao vittoriano ciao vittorio
ciò vivaldo
ciao viviano blood mio
ciao voting oh ciao wolfango ciao
vulmaro e ciao vulpiano
nicola p
ciao vara
ciao valentina ciao valeria ciao
valeriana giovan da ciò vanessa ciao
bella ciao vennero ciao veneranda ciò
venere ciao venusta ciao vera
ciao verdiana ciò verena ciao variano
ciao verdiana ciao veronica
ciao biljana ciao film ciao vincenza ciò
viola ciao violante ciò virginia
ciao visse a ciò vittoria e ciao viviano
no mi con la w maschili
ciao altero
nomico la w femminili ciao manda
un amico la z maschi ciao sapete ochoa
zaccaria cosa che faccio da 90 cia
tenacia zenaide cialde medio ciao zeno
ciò se non piace al seno nei soggetti
coach all'odio sosimo
nomi con la z
ciao bambina ciao zaira salza ma
causalità ciao zarina ciao zelinda ciao
zenobia ciao zita ciao zone e ciao dosi
un saluto a tutti
vi saluto tutti spero che questo video
vi sia piaciuto cosa bisognerà me piace
discreta che non ci ha seguito
da ragazzi
questo periodo